when I notice these year's nominees for
foreign language film all showcases
special ability of movies to transport
us in space and time an outpost in
Afghanistan a Nazi concentration camp a
conservative Turkish village the Amazon
rainforest and the Middle East during
World War one all of this year's films
take place on battlefields of one sort
or another the filmmakers explore the
fundamental aspects of humanity that
both divide us and sometimes bind us
together here are the nominees for Best
Foreign Language Film from Colombia
embrace of the serpent directed by Sarah
Guerra from France Mustang directed by
James Gunn's a are divine
hungry son of Saul Dracul by las Lomas
from Jordan deep directed by an Ozzy
Allen Warren from Denmark a war directed
by two Bs
and the Oscar goes to
son of soul Hungary
this is the second Oscar and ninth
nomination for Hungary
you
well thanks to the Academy for this
incredible honor thank you for to Sony
Pictures Classics Don Berna
Tom Barnard Michael Barker for
supporting us
thanks to Hungary for funding this film
I want to share this with gays Aurora my
main actor and the incredible cast and
crew that believed in this project when
no one no one else did you know even in
the darkest hours of mankind when in the
darkest hours of mankind there's there
might be a voice within us that allows
us to remain human that's the hope of
this film thank you very much